The sound isn't the tail It's the
lifeline that connects your true feelings and the spiritual body
me I'm going to cut that thing w
Major
[music]
Driving
Okay, you're not headed for a fight in the first place B Don't
imitate like a patch
You can't do anything, can you?
I didn't have one, so I've been looking for a long
time
.
My name is the opposition Party
Everyone stays here with rice balls
Karina is my
servant Naha is leading the vessel The sound is an order I'm happy
It
was snowing Wooden frame
Love
Design
[Music]
[Applause]  ]
Just take it slow and if it's below civilization,
I've brought a player who's full of face empty and
billed.
It
's clear and the smell that came to the sky
Unexpected opening
song The touch of goodbye beats off kicks ah ah
meme da da da da da da da da da da da da
standing up